Everyone knows that at the beginning it happens
all the time…
...and then as relationships gets longer,
it doesn’t.
We say it’s because we’re too busy, or
tired - or just not IN THE MOOD
But why does this important ‘mood’ disappear?
To understand excitement, we have to go back
the early days, when we were deeply in the
mood pretty much every hour.
What was exciting was our ability to touch,
hold, stroke
in short, POSSESS
someone who wasn’t entirely within our reach:
someone who was independent and free to walk
away from us - and yet miraculously was choosing
not to do so.
Expressed as an equation:
SEXINESS = POSSESSION + FREEDOM
The thrilling desire to be within and inside
the body of another person stems from an active,
mesmerised wonder that they’ve allowed us
to be so close and, somewhere in the semi-conscious
mind, a worried sense they might
not do so forever.
Unfortunately, liking someone means we almost
always want to reduce their ability to survive
without us: in the nicest way, we relentlessly
try to erode the freedom of the person we
love.
And so gradually, we kill the very spirit
of independence that had underpinned our desire
from the outset.
There’s something else that wears away at
the sex drive: FEAR. Odd though it might sound,
asking someone to have sex with us generally
has an element of risk attached to it.
The other person might say NO or even, at
the limit:
Sex is a REQUEST.
And in order to make a request, we have to
feel reasonably safe about rejection.
At the start, we do feel that safety because
- even though we don’t know our lovers so
well - we’re independent: we have our own
routines, options and autonomy…
If it didn’t work out, we could walk away.
Out of love, we throw away the supports to our
independent lives.
We knit ourselves together. We no longer have
very much we can squarely call our own any
more. We also have to make requests of them
all the time: we want them to buy that sofa
we like,
we want very badly not to go and see their
parents for Christmas…
we rely on their income while we go back and
study for a new qualification...
In the circumstances, yet another request
seems like it might really be one too many.
So we don’t bring up that thing we want
to do with the mask.
or with the thigh high boots
We no longer have the will to lose face
in front of our daily negotiating
partner.
It might just be easier to leave things alone
Strangely, there is one thing that’s almost
guaranteed to revive sex: a huge argument
with a genuine possibility of separation
Major bust-ups have a curious habit of ending
up in the bedroom
because they bring back to light two things
whose apparent absence had gravely undermined
sex.
Firstly: the sense that you could both theoretically
walk away
And secondly, the sense that you could, though
it wouldn’t necessarily be easy, survive
independently
You could, if you really wanted, build up
you own castle once more,
recover your own destiny, and greet existence
as an independent soul.
Good sex needs all this. It is built out of
a feeling of freedom and of buoyant self-confidence
- the very things that can become oddly so
scarce with time.
To get back to the thrill of the early days,
we need to learn the deepest and best lessons
of breaking up, ideally without having to
go through the very sad and painful process
of actually doing so.